[Music]
equality between men and women means two
things for me fairness and freedom it's
a human right issue equality is not only
a principle it's a mindset men women are
equal this should be obvious
a long time ago in a competition for a
job but not later in politics yes of
course
sometimes it was but this only pushed me
to work much more to get it know then
you can imagine why but I've often
witnessed in justices suffered by my
female colleagues so I'm well aware of
how gender can unfortunately be an
obstacle to people's careers and this is
why it has to stop now
supporting equal access to health care
regardless of gender and the European
Union third health program personally as
I mother of three I think work-life
balance this is the most important thing
we appointed more female managers is
European ooing Commission today almost
40% of our managers are women
we will reach gender equality in our
lifetime if we keep on fighting
day by day then I can say my daughters
and my sons will be equally treated in
the European Union yes we are determined
to achieve this it is our common goal we
are not there yet but Europe is a
pioneer and I believe we should continue
our work to lead by example for the rest
of the world
[Music]
you